moment dann wollen wir kennen uns doch
ich bin's der jochen bischoff wenn wir
ein trocken das ist unser job ist das
nimmer so sei das gewesen sein
hauptschule auf der schanz br ich die
atompolitik hat und am wandert hat du
hast das du niedergerissen nein was
haben wir gestern rahmen name ist jörg
friedrich ein mix jörg friedrich klausi
und nach dem spiel haben wir doch wie
weit aufgerissen ich bin schwul so lange
schon immer diese saison damit immer uns
vielleicht doch mit schönen tag noch
gleichstand
servus hockey da ist der klausi du
glaubst es nicht wer mir gerade mein weg
lassen der jochen ist wieder in
ingolstadt und noch das gleiche
arschloch wie domes im piusviertel